all right I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis he's going
to join us here live in just a few
moments we have a lot to go over with
him of course but first the FBI versus
America that's the focus of tonight's
angle
[Music]
do you ever stop during the course of
your day and wonder how did things get
so off track in America
now I'm just not talking about the lousy
economy or high prices either
a lot of our Bedrock values seem to be
in short supply
respect for elders respect for our
history respect for our constitution
how about just basic decency you just
put a magazine in it you're still trying
to load it
stupid I'm gonna kill you I hope she
knows when I come back she's gonna die
the rank depravity the viciousness the
Casual nature of the violence today
seems different at least from what I
remember seeing growing up
now one thing is obvious when we can't
expect our next Generations to respect
the rule of law
we can't we certainly can't if our own
FBI is perceived to be flouting the
basic idea of equal justice under the
law
operating within an obvious political
bias as it did recently against my next
guest Mark Houck a pro-life activist in
Pennsylvania he's going to tell his
story it was all exposed today though
during the grilling of A.G Merrick
Garland
this is a case where a Catholic pro-life
demonstrator father was accused of
disorderly conduct in front of an
abortion Center
the local prosecutor the Philadelphia
district attorney who is a Democrat a
liberal very Progressive declined to
prosecute and then after all of that
your justice department sent between 20
and 30 armed agents in the early morning
hours to the house private residence to
arrest this guy
after he had offered to turn himself in
voluntarily here's the photo once again
you can see belong guns you can see the
ballistic Shields
all I know is what the FBI has said
which is that they made decisions on the
ground as to what was safest and easiest
are you telling me that in your opinion
as attorney general it was objectively
necessary to use 20 or 30 SWAT style
agents with long guns and Ballistic
shields for these people what I'm saying
is that decisions about how to go about
this were made on the ground by fbias so
you said that is a disgraceful
performance by your justice department
and a disgraceful use of resources
now Holly was masterful and everyone
including liberals know that the FBI
gives kid gloves treatment a liberal Act
mash and loot
now there's little to no chance that
they're going to be treated like Mr
Houck
Garland had pathetic excuses but Senator
Lee he had the facts
in 2022 and for the first couple of
months of 2023
doj's announced charges against 34
individuals for blocking access to or
vandalizing abortion clinics
and there have been over 81 reported
attacks on pregnancy centers 130 attacks
on Catholic churches since the leak of
the Dobbs decision and only two
individuals have been charged so how do
you explain this disparity
uh uh by reference to anything other
than politicization of what's happening
there I will say you are quite right
there are many more prosecutions with
respect uh to the um blocking of the uh
of the abortion centers but that is
generally because they are those actions
are taken in uh with photography at the
time
um uh during the daylight and uh seeing
the person who did it is quite easy
the those who are attacking the
Pregnancy Resources centers uh which is
a hard thing to do are doing this at
night in the dark
the pro- sunshine bias I got it oh my
goodness Garland has zero credibility
and when it was cruises time to question
him oh boy
but in the wake of the leak of the Dobbs
decision
when rioters descended at the homes of
six Supreme Court Justices night after
night after night you did nothing when
extremist groups like Ruth sent us and
Jane's Revenge openly organized
campaigns of harassment at the homes of
justices you sat on your hands
when these same groups posted online
information about where the justices
worship
or their home addresses or where their
kids went to school you again sat on
your hands and did nothing has the
Department of Justice brought even a
single case under the statute the job of
the United States Marshals is to defend
the lives so the answer is no is to
defend the lives of the justices and
that's their number one priority they
have are you unwilling to say no the
answer is no you know it's no I know
it's no everyone in this in this hearing
room knows it's no
well of course it is well Garland is
just another Biden Administration
official who refuses any accountability
he's not going to apologize for what's
happening because this is their plan
to weaponize the doj that's what they
need to do to defeat Republicans or so
they think
now look at how they've treated some of
the January 6 defendants that we've
documented here on the angle held in
solitary confinement for parading
through the capital years in jail
it's why the release of those tapes is
so important
the FBI lies and the doj covers forum
and nowhere did we see this bias used
more egregiously than against Donald
Trump
I believe your intention and I believe
it's a political intention to indict
president Trump became infinitely harder
when classified documents were
discovered repeatedly at President
Biden's multiple residences those were
first discovered on November 2nd six
days before the prior Election
Department of Justice was notified on
November 4th and yet miraculously there
was no leak
about the classified documents at
President Biden's home
when it politically benefited
the effort to go after and charge Donald
Trump doj League leaks under all
circumstances are inappropriate and they
are not directed by anyone in the that's
called deflect and deny oh of course
Lakes are inappropriate always
and they're apparently carried out by a
ghost
no no who did it ever now Garland
certainly didn't seem as worked up about
that as the FBI's Richmond field office
was about Catholics who attend the Latin
Mass
when Garland was pressed on this
memorandum that basically targeted
traditionalist Catholics
there was nowhere to go but well join
the outrage
they advocated for and I quote the
exploration of new avenues for tripwire
and Source development against
traditionalist Catholics it's their
language including those who favor the
Latin Mass
attorney general are you cultivating
sources and spies in Latin Mass parishes
how did it happen that's what they're
looking into but I'm totally in
agreement with you that document is
appalling
well the bottom line is those Republican
Senators conclusively demonstrated that
our doj doesn't care that our laws
aren't being applied equally to their
political opponents where why isn't the
guy in the Richmond field office fired
is that why is he still or is she still
working there
you know there's simply too many
indefensible examples out there from
targeting Trump with that bogus Russian
collusion nonsense to targeting parents
at school board meetings
so now it's up to Republicans to use the
power of the purse to stop once and for
all this madness
the politicization of the department is
a problem
and you can tell your department not a
chance in hell we're going to be
reauthorizing that thing without some
major major reforms your department is
not trusted because it has been
politicized
without trust in government things will
continue to spiral in the United States
the way you vote the church you attend
should never affect the way the
government especially the FBI with all
the powers it has
to treat you under the law any
differently
the use of federal power to punish
political adversaries
is what we expect in Beijing maybe
Moscow but not in Washington
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else